>> Laura: UNDER PRESSURE
TONIGHT, THE UNIVERSITY OF
CONNECTICUT FINALLY LET STUDENTS
SPONSOR A CONSERVATIVE SPEAKER
ON CAMPUS AGAIN.
THIS IS AFTER VIOLENT PROTESTS
ERUPTED OUTSIDE AND INSIDE THE
HALL WHERE THE GATEWAY POND AND
ITS SPOKE BACK IN NOVEMBER.
AT THE DAILY WIRE'S BEN SHAPIRO
JUST WRAPPED UP A SPEECH HOSTED
BY THE COLLEGE REPUBLICANS.
HERE'S A SAMPLE.
>> SOMETHING HAS TO BE DONE
ABOUT A SYSTEM WHERE A FEW
CRAZED LEFTISTS DECIDE THEY
DON'T WANT TO HEAR SOMEBODY
SPEAK AND FOR PEOPLE FROM THE
OUTSIDE WHO PAY TAXES TO
UNIVERSITIES LIKE THIS ONE CAN'T
GET IN.
IT'S A GREAT THING UNIVERSITIES
HAVE PEOPLE LIKE ME AND YES LIKE
THE PERSON WHO IS SPEAKING
OPPOSITE ME ON THIS CAMPUS TO
GIVE A VARIATION OF IDEAS.
>> Laura: OF THOSE WORDS SO
DANGEROUS!
THE UNIVERSITY ACTUALLY
OFFERED -- I KID YOU NOT --
COUNSELING TO STUDENTS WHO MIGHT
BE UPSET EVEN AT THE MENTION OF
GUY TO ME.
EXCLUSIVELY IN A NEW SEGMENT WE
ARE CALLING "BACK-TO-SCHOOL."
KIND OF A RODNEY DANGERFIELD
THING.
DID YOU TRAUMATIZE SNOWFLAKES ON
CAMPUS TONIGHT?
YOU LOOK SO JUST INNOCENT AND
NICE, AND THEY SEEMED VERY UPSET
ABOUT THE PROSPECT OF YOUR
ARRIVING.
YOU ARE IN THE STORES CAMPUS,
CORRECT?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
IT WAS VERY INTIMIDATING.
BENEATH THIS INNOCUOUS EXTERIOR
RIPPED AT LEAST ONE GUY'S THROAT
OUT.
IN ACTUALITY NONE OF THOSE
THINGS HAPPENED OF COURSE.
THIS IS WHAT'S SO FUNNY.
THIS IS THE LAST CAMPUS WHERE
THEY HAD TO BRING OUT DOZENS OF
SECURITY MEMBERS, DOZENS OF
COPS, THE STADIUMS WERE'S MORE
ON-CALL APPARENTLY BECAUSE OF
WHAT HAPPENED WHEN LUCIAN CAME
WHAT I WAS AT BERKELEY THEY HAD
TO BRING HUNDREDS OF POLICE
OFFICERS.
WHEN I WAS AT NORTHWESTERN THEY
BOUND THE PUBLIC FROM COMING.
WHEN I WAS AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
WISCONSIN OF THE FRONT OF THE
STAGE WAS TAKEN OVER.
WHEN I WAS AT CAL STATE A NEAR
RIOT BROKE OUT.
TONIGHT WAS ACTUALLY RELATIVELY
WITH THE FACT THAT THE
UNIVERSITY REALLY DID ITS JOB
IT'S COLD, THESE ARE FAIR
WEATHER PROTESTERS.
THEY WILL NOT SHOW UP WHEN IT'S
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
ALLOWED AND IS LIMITED.
IF YOU ARE FROM AN OUTSIDE GROUP
YOU WEREN'T ALLOWED TO COME EVEN
THOUGH THERE WERE ALL THE
SECURITY OFFICES AVAILABLE.
>> Laura: WAS A PACKED OUT?
WAS AT A FULL AUDITORIUM?
>> THEY COULD HAVE GIVEN US
ALL OF THEM FULL.
BUT THEY DID PREVENT PEOPLE
WANTING TO COME IN FROM THE
OUTSIDE.
I WAS TOLD BY THE COLLEGE
REPUBLICANS THERE WERE ANOTHER
6-700 PEOPLE WHO WERE TURNED
AWAY.
IF YOU WERE A TAX PAYING MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC THEY WOULDN'T
ALLOW YOU.
>> Laura: NEW SONG LIKE
DONALD TRUMP.
I HAD 700 PEOPLE OUTSIDE AND
THEY COULDN'T GET IN.
THERE WERE 10,000 PEOPLE OUTSID
OUTSIDE!
WE HAVE A CLIP -- WE HAVE A CLIP
OF A STUDENT WHO ACTUALLY WANTED
TO GET IN TONIGHT.
LET'S WATCH.
>> THEY BASICALLY SAID THAT
THERE'S OPEN SEATS AND ALSO
UNCLAIMED WRISTBANDS, THEY WILL
STILL NOT LET US IN TO THE
ACTUAL EVENT.
>> DID THEY TELL YOU WHY?
>> NO.
THEY JUST SAID THEY ARE NOT THE
PEOPLE TO TALK TO.
THERE'S NOBODY THAT WILL COME IN
AND TALK TO US AND EVEN IF THERE
IS SOMEBODY INSIDE THERE THAT
COULD HELP US OR COULD KIND OF
SORT THIS OUT, THEY ARE NOT
GOING TO COME OUT AND TALK TO
US.
>> WHAT YOU MAKE OF THAT?
>> THEY WANT US TO GO TO THIS
EVENT.
>> WHY?
>> BECAUSE IT'S BEEN SHAPIRO.
>> Laura: I COULDN'T TELL HER
MY CLIP OR BY THE LOOK OF THE
GUY WHETHER HE WAS A FRIEND OR A
FOE.
I WAS GUESSING FOE BUT THEN AT
THE END I SAID FRIEND.
I COULDN'T REALLY TELL.
BUT APPARENTLY -- THEY WERE LIKE
POOR PEOPLE WANT TO COME IN, YOU
CAN'T GO!
AT SOME POINT -- TWO OF MY
BROTHERS WENT TO UCONN SO I KNOW
THE CAMPUS.
IT WAS A LONG TIME AGO BUT I
KNOW IT QUITE WELL.
SPEAK.
IT CAN'T POSSIBLY.
>> I DON'T THINK THAT IT IS.
AS I SAID IN THE SPEECH, IF YOU
ACTUALLY HAVE TO GO SEEK MENTAL
HEALTH COUNSELING BECAUSE WE
HAVE THAT I'M COMING TO CAMPUS,
YOU PROBABLY NEED TO SEEK MENTAL
THAT CENSORSHIP IS TAKING PLACE.
AS I'VE SAID, THERE ARE A BUNCH
PEOPLE TO COME AND ACTUALLY HAVE
THIS.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED AT
WHO CAME SAME-DAY FROM ATTENDING
WHO CAME SAME-DAY FROM ATTENDIN
HAPPENING FOR A BUNCH OF
CONSERVATIVE SPEAKERS AROUND THE
ANITA HILL SPOKE AT UCONN LAST
WEEK AND IT WAS COMPLETELY OPEN
TO THE PUBLIC.
THREATS AND THEN PRESUMABLY THE
ENTIRE PUBLIC IS BARRED FROM
COMING IN THE NAME OF SAFETY, OF
YOU HAVE ACCESS TO CARE IN
THEORY, BUT YOU DON'T REALLY
HAVE CARE.
YOU ARE THERE, BUT YOU CAN'T
REALLY HEAR YOU.
I JUST HAVE TO RE-EVENT, I WAS
LIKE CRYING LAUGHING, THE
DIVERSITY OFFICER AT UCONN.
IN HER LETTER THAT JUST WENT OUT
BEFORE YOUR SPEECH -- WE
UNDERSTAND EVEN THE THOUGHT OF
AN INDIVIDUAL COMING TO CAMPUS
WITH THE VIEWS THAT MR. SHAPIRO
EXPRESSES CAN BE CONCERNING AND
EVEN HURTFUL.
FEELINGS ABOUT THIS ISSUE,
STUDENTS.
I WANT TO GO PAY HER A VISIT AND
SAY I'VE HAD A TOUGH DAY TODAY
AND I REALLY NEED JUST A HUG.
I JUST NEED A HUG.
YOU LOOK GOOD.
YOU LOOK LIKE YOU HAD FUN
AND I WILL SAY THIS, THERE IS NO
MORE USELESS TITLE ON CAMPUS
THAN CHIEF DIVERSITY OFFICER,
WHOSE ENTIRE JOB IS JUST TO